joy reid joy reed one of the most
honest people on msnbc in in that she is
honest about her radicalism she just
posted a tick tock
where she made clear the facts of the
kyle written house case or jacob blake
or whatever none of that
matters she hates white men and whatever
white men do is evil
it's car written house trial
it reminded a lot of people of something
something i just can't remember what it
was
oh
the brett kavanaugh hearings in which
brett kavanaugh who had been accused by
a high school friend of committing
sexual abuse of her
cried his way through
the hearings to make him a permanent
member
and associate justice of the united
states supreme court
and his tears turned out to be more
powerful than the tears of christine
blasey ford which were the tears of an
alleged victim but in america there's a
thing
about both white vigilantism
and white tears
particularly
male white tears
really white tears in general because
that's what carrots are right they carry
out and then as soon as you get caught
green water works
[Music]
white men can get away with that too and
it has the same effect even as
the right tries to politicize the idea
that masculinity is being robbed from
american men by multiculturalism and
wokism
they still want to be able to have their
tears
you white men with your white tears now
joy reid again because
i'm not sure the iq is is popping past
double digits
joy reid
undermines her own argument she says
white male tears are bad and you saw
this with the brett kavanaugh case and
his tears mattered more than white white
women's tears in that in that case
christine blasey ford who was accusing
brett kavanaugh of all sorts of terrible
things even though christine blasey ford
couldn't even prove that she ever met
the guy
but then two seconds later she says but
white women's tears are terrible too
okay well then who cares about christine
blasey ford it's
pretty clear that joy reid just hates
white people
and
and she hates men and so she
specifically hates white men since 2015
over 100 000 independent farms and
ranches in the united states have shut
down why because foreign meat are
robbing americans of their livelihoods
and robbing you of great flavor that's
why the good ranchers are here to
support local american farms and help
you make great american meals
that that product of usa tag has been
stolen by foreign countries they process
their meat here and then label it like
it came from the united states and
because of these
labeling laws that favor foreign
imported meat the american rancher and
the american consumer both get a raw
deal go check out good ranchers they've
got incredible beef wonderful chicken i
love the burgers to me the burgers are
just out of this freaking world go to
goodranchers.com
right now
get 10 free bistro fillets and in
addition if you subscribe you will save
25
off each subscription box of
mouth-watering american meats for
life
these boxes will show up on schedule
right to your door so right now you'll
get 10 free bistro fillets which is 100
value free express shipping and 25
off your monthly subscription for life
at goodranchers.com knowles that is
goodrangers.com slash knowles use code
knowles to check out 10 free beast or
filets free express shipping and 25
off your monthly subscription for life
goodrangers.com
knowles in brett kavanaugh's case there
was no evidence against him whatsoever
none of the and some of the charges were
so outlandish that now the life doesn't
even bring them up like that woman who
said that he gang raped her
and she she was the client of michael
avenatti and they were both disgraced
very quickly so then they sort of went
away but even christine blasey ford her
story fell apart she had no evidence
whatsoever
doesn't matter
brett kavanaugh
faces a completely unsubstantiated
serious allegation and then the minute
he defends himself the left attacks him
even more and makes fun of him for that
same thing here with kyle rittenhouse
the state the prosecutors have no
evidence against him whatsoever they
push a bunch of lies actually the media
push a bunch of lies about him then when
the defense knocks down those lies and
shows that all the evidence is on his
side he gets really worked up reliving
the drama of this of this night and then
they make fun of him for that and what
it is
is just scapegoating right and the thing
about scapegoating is
you never realize that you're the one
doing the scapegoating no one threat all
of human history has ever thought we are
scapegoating people right now the people
who scapegoat others always think
they're on the side of justice and so in
this case what the left does in this
country and the left is the dominant
regime in this country they scapegoat
specifically straight white men
it is the only group of people that you
are allowed
that it is socially acceptable to
discriminate against that it is legal to
discriminate against and actually that
it is encouraged to discriminate against
if joy reid or someone like joy reid
went on tv and started talking about how
awful black women are and how black men
are the bane of existence then
she would be ostracized or even face
charges of hate speech but but the only
group you're allowed to scapegoat are
straight white men and you're seeing
this play out
in brett kavanaugh
in the kyle rittenhouse trial it's much
bigger even we say that self-defense is
on trial here sure yeah they say the
second amendment's on trial here sure
but there's actually this much bigger
social problem which is the increasing
scapegoating of one specific group of
people i'm glad you liked that clip
now please ring the bell
please subscribe
leave me a comment and if youtube is not
totally your thing and you're not
getting notifications or whatever head
on over to apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
podcasts that's going to be the more
reliable option to make sure you never
miss an episode we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]